donc c'est un arabe qui se fait arrêter
à la douane par un douanier parce qu'il
fait du trafic de légumes de fruits et
légumes donc s'arrêter à la douane ou
donnez lui d'écouter c'est la sixième
fois qu'on se rattrape sur mac ou fille
et dit que la prochaine fois qu'on vous
attrape il y aura une sanction
et qui dit ok to dance pas grave et/ou
et repart avec ses légumes et tous le
lendemain il revient à le douanier la
trappe il en peut plus dire écoutez
monsieur makhloufi baisser notre
pantalon mais c'est votre pantalon
monsieur lacouchie il baisse son
pantalon comme ça et il avait ramené un
cageot d'olive avec lui le douanier
prend les olives et lui mais dans les
faits ce cos milieu olive 3 au leader
effacés oui et il a tablé sur mac ou fiq
est mort de rire il doit les rigoles
doit y est dit mais pourquoi vous
rigolez et dès la semaine dernière j'ai
mon copain qui s'est fait arrêter avec
des pastèques
[Applaudissements]
ces deux mais qui travaille dans la même
boîte sauf que là c'est le pdg nôtres
c'est le mec qui fait le ménage
ils se croisent dans le parking chacun
dans sa voiture y en a elles une clio
pourri éclaté qui sert à rien et l'outil
les dans une porsche magnifique mecs
dans sa clio i luz avait fait que effet
patron bluetooth toit de voiture
petit et consulats et ses nombreuses une
porsche louis g le bluetooth là moi
aussi et là le brut us dans sa clio des
classes mais qui m'a halluciné et s'ils
n'ont pas trop salée la télé dans votre
voiture quotidien oui oui j'ai le tennis
avec 4 sièges prends tu m'emmerdes jeudi
j'en ai j'en ai bien moi aussi un écran
plat dans la crise c'est quoi cette
pièce est elle pas trop revenir dessus
vous avez un frigo votre voiture saisie
oui j'ai un frigo dans chaque portière
tu vas me faire chier toute la journée
avec ça et à moi aussi il a un gros
frigo congélateur et c'est bon et
attendez vous avez un lit dans votre
voiture
j'ai pas de licques et après ce que moi
jarry est un vrai lit dans sa clio et
des escales ce qu'il est blessé dans son
ego toi ils foncent sur ses portes jeudi
à taraz bon vous allez me [ __ ] un lit
dans ma voiture et vous mettez tout un
matelas sommiers de la soie du satin
vous ne faites péter le meilleur line
qui a jamais eu dans une voiture il fait
ça ça lui coûte une blinde un truc de
fou il revient le lendemain et dimanche
je vais retrouver le mec les dans le
parking ils ne trouvent pas et trouve un
moment sa voiture comme ça stationner
que le contact
il tape mec sort pas il retape le mec
sort toujours pas il repart fort le mec
sort il quoi direct j'ai mis un lilas
mon gars tu as déjà vu un lit comme ça
dans une voiture [ __ ] c'est pour les
conneries comme ça que tu m'as fait
sortir de la piscine
[Applaudissements]
alors moi c'est ça ce professionnel
c'est dans un petit village de
convaincre tout le monde se connaît et
le vin qu'il avait un confessionnal vie
mon père voilà j'ai trompé ma femme et
le curé dit avec qui et là le mec ne
répond pas et le curé donc licence j'ai
dit bon on dit c'est pas grave laissez
moi deviner il dit c'est la femme du
boulanger sésame et dit non non mon père
non bon allez assez infâme du gendarme
alors dit non non non mon père non alors
dit je sais c'est la femme du chef de
gare et le oui qui dit non c'était une
[ __ ] mais merci pour les bonnes adresses
[Applaudissements]
ces deux potes qui jouent au tennis tous
les mercredis après midi ensemble et un
jour il y en a un des deux qui se rend
compte que son pote à 1 tentera de
sauter sa femme depuis six mois donc il
est très très vénère ne parle pas il
attend le mercredi suivant
et là il en vient aux chats détective
privé livre là tu vas tu vas suivre ma
femme mais tu fais tout ce qu'il faut il
faut je suis journée sur le détective
revient avec une panoplie de photos tu
vois avec sa femme et son pote dans
toutes les positions l'épuisement
possible que gars qui écrase une larme
il prend toutes les photos et le
mercredi ils arrivent dans le vestiaire
de du tennis a dit commence à se ranger
hélas on peut tu arrives en sifflotant
et là ils arrêtent différent il faut que
tu vois ça et ils étalent sur la table
toutes les photos m safram dans toutes
les positions et fait alors qu'est ce
que tu dis des lots divers
écoute je vais prendre celle là
- chez les c'est le week end à lourdes
avec ma femme et je dis alors vas-y
alors y'a pas eu de miracle 1 je suis
revenue avec elle sur les ballons petit
c'est un prof d'histoire qui donne un
cours particulier à 20 blonde et tout
d'un coup du mans ou concentrez vous
mesdemoiselles alors x en une grande
carte du monde comme saïdi où se trouve
l'amérique et tout d'un coup il ya
nicole elle se lève comme ça qu'elle
fait l'amérique c'est là alors elle
pointe du doigt comme ça très bien
nicole super concentré vous
mesdemoiselles qui a découvert
l'amérique hélène 19 nana se lèvent et
font passer nico
[Applaudissements]
alors si histoire belge mais sous ton
contrôle avec l'accent que je maîtrisais
st berne test à un couple de belges et
sa femme lui dit à son mari il faudrait
que tu change vraiment le papier pas dis
moi oui oui comment faire un petit coup
tu devrais aller demander à roger en
dessous il a fait la semaine dernière
il descend il fait roger excuse moi te
déranger ma femme voudrait qu'on refasse
le papier paraît que tu l'as fait du oui
j'en ai fait et dit combien il faut de
rouleaux pas du 32 des trente deux
rouleaux doux et 32 rouleau il fâché le
tapissier ils achètent 32 rouleau il y
passe quatre jours il appelle sa femme
il y là vraiment je ne comprends pas a
dit mme à quoi va exiger tout à pister
un tout le moindre recoin
il me reste quatre rouleaux indien bon
c'est étrange pourtant j'ai demandé à
oger un gîte exactement ce qui m'a dit
et on a la même surface il me laisse
quatre rouleaux m'a dit va lui demander
qu ils descendent vergès tu dois te
déranger mais j'ai fais comme tu m'as
dit j'ai acheté 32 rouleau il me reste
quatre bases y mollo donc c'est bien si
mouloud
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mollo entre les deux sites choisis
mouloud
vas-y boulou dsk il est dans un train
ouais dans un compartiment en première
un con quoi ta gueule femme vient de
taille alors c'est quoi alors dsk il est
dans un train en premières et les seules
dans un compartiment arrive une femme
assez chic elle s'assoit en face dsk ils
bouffent des crevettes micromètres
qu'importe vous des crevettes au bout de
dix minutes après minutes et monsieur
est dans le train quand on n'est pas au
restaurant n'est pas la maison ça sent
fort vos crevettes dit écoutez ma la
bouffe est ce que vous voulez moi je
bouffe ce que je veux dire écoutez je
faisais reconnu monsieur dsk vous avez
été patron du fmi
vous avez failli être président de la
république vous êtes pris les pieds dans
le tapis et vous avez failli passer
votre vie en taule moi vous ne
m'impressione pas aux crevettes ça pue
la preuve elle ouvre la fenêtre et
balancent tout fait quoi mais de quel
droit vous balancer mais croisette le
ton monte
ils sont à deux doigts nus romain et
tout arrive le contrôleur contrôleur dit
c'est quoi ce bordel qu'est ce qui se
passe et la fab s il se passe que
monsieur dsk que vous avez reconnu il a
essayé de me violer il m'a fait des
attouchements d'ailleurs santé ses
doigts c'est la loi
[Applaudissements]
avec